in terms of China relations how
significant is this visit and the fact
that one year has now actually met the
the Prime Minister not just Sergey
lavrov
um well I think he's he's due to be
meeting the president
um and I think it's very significant
this is the end of a European tour for
one year he was at the Munich security
conference where the U.S Secretary of
State had very Stern words for him
saying
um we warn you strongly against uh
supplying lethal Force to Russia
um Anthony blinken says that China is
pursuing a dual strategy on the one hand
uh proclaiming that it wants to pursue
peace and there are reports that the
Chinese Premiere are a Xi Jinping on
Friday will actually deliver some kind
of speech a demanding piece uh to come
commemorate the one-year anniversary of
this war
um and yet at the same time there he is
with the head of the security Council
yesterday Nicola Nikolai Patriot who's
pretty much the most hawkish of
President Putin's advisors meeting the
foreign minister this morning and
meeting President Putin reportedly also
preparing a summit between the Chinese
and the Russian leaders
um and uh you know the the discussion
with Patrick Chef yesterday talked about
the fact that China and Russia would
stand against unilateral bullying that
they would pursue a multilateral world a
multi-polar world all the kind of
rhetoric that we hear from Russia so I
don't think uh China is a neutral
Arbiter in all of this and I think it is
extremely significant that um they are
in Moscow together it's certainly very
significant for Vladimir Putin's
attempts to make it look like he is not
isolated the question really is is
Anthony blinken Wright is China going to
throw its uh Aid in militarily which I
think up to this point it has not
because of the risk of secondary
sanctions and the fact that China
doesn't want to risk its connections
with the global economy just to back
um Russia it has a you know has has
maintained a fairly
um constrained position on the war in
Ukraine it refuses to call it a war it
uses Vladimir Putin's terminology of a
special military operation
um we shall have to see it will depend
on the outcome of the next uh meetings
that we see between these uh two Powers
I'm outside the lujiniki stadium where
Vladimir Putin presumably be after this
meeting with Wang years due to appear on
the stage soon it is bitterly cold here
and there are tens if not hundreds of
thousands of people that Stadium can fit
about 200 000 people in it we've seen uh
buses bringing people here a lot of
people are organized by State
Corporations to come universities we've
spoken to students who say that they
were told to come and there are quite a
few people already leaving you know you
take the picture and then you go but
that said pretty much everybody that
we've spoken to has had a very patriotic
mindset they believe that the West is
out to get them they believe that this
war is a good thing young men I've
spoken to said that they would go and
fight for their motherland uh if there
was another round of mobilization if it
was called upon them
um I'm like why why are you fighting why
are you defending their motherland they
don't really know they don't really have
much to say
um but they believe Vladimir Putin they
believe is rhetoric and we're about to
hear another one of those um speeches
which I'm sure will cast damnation on
the west just as we heard yesterday in
his address and Proclaim Russian unity
and certainly it does feel from my
reporting here over the past year that
that liberal voice that we did used to
hear grows fainter and fainter